I also got vaginal rejuvenation - Oh on
camera I'm this happy hour and Kelly
Dodd is here you're back for more I am
more punishment let's cheers to your
second season yeah welcome back thank
you how do you feel about this season um
I am loving this season did you go in
differently than you did your first
season this season I came in here
thinking you know I don't want to be
like a negative Nancy I don't want to be
portrayed as like being dark or like you
know I just it's all myself and I wanted
to change you wanted to show what you
considered to be the real you the real
me yes I want people see the real me
let's dive into some of the stuff we're
gonna see this year you've got a breast
reduction on the show this year good why
that surgery and why documented on TV
they were so large and in charge and
there's a lot of women that are 40s and
they you know have boobs hanging down
here and near 40 you're getting older
and you need to maintain I also got
vaginal rejuvenation - Oh on camera okay
yeah are we happy with the results
across the board I am yes okay I like
this we are seeing a new Kelly partially
because you have some new parts exactly
why do it on TV did you want women to
know this is the thing you can do and to
feel comfortable talking about it we are
in a reality show and I wasn't happy
with my boobs you feel like you want to
get in the game you have to maintain
yourself
I wanted women to know that in our
forties you can make yourself look sexy
you can make yourself look good and the
vaginal rejuvenation was more for a lot
of women have are embarrassed to talk
about you know when you have kids you
get stressing and incontinence and get a
little bit of leakage I know it's gross
that's why a lot of women don't talk
about it but that's reality but it's the
reality and you can do something about
it listen you don't have to have like
wear a pad all the time you don't have
to worry about jumping up and down you
don't have to like worry about coughing
or laughing you know what I mean you can
go running like there's things that you
can do to help yourself be better well
there we go let's cheers to that
what you said get back in the game but
you're you're still married right know
what I'm saying like like you can either
decide like you know when you're 40s
you can either decide to be like a mom
and be frumpy and dumpy or you can
choose the legs look good
you